okay guys so I have been excited about
this movie for a while it's a return of
arnold schwarzenegger
one of my childhood action heroes back
in a movie directed by the guy who made
the good the bad and the weird how was
this movie is it fun is it awesome does
it remind me of the good old Arnold
Schwarzenegger days let's talk about the
last stand
the last stand as I said in my intro is
directed by the director of the good the
bad and the weird this guy has an
interesting visual style and it
definitely has a parent in this movie in
which Arnold Schwarzenegger plays a
sheriff and there's this escaped
fugitive in a car like the fastest
Karluk ever apparently who's coming down
through the United States is going to
cross over to the Mexican border the
last stop between that Mexican border
and this escaped fugitive is this little
town that Arnold Schwarzenegger is a
sheriff of and he will not let that
happen because as you heard in the
trailer I had a loss coming
that's my heart oh so it's figured oh
yeah that was so bad when you go into
the last stand there's something you
have to understand there are two
different types of Arnold Schwarzenegger
action movies that are good you made a
few clunkers but of the good ones he
made you get these really epic like
science fiction incredibly amazing
awesome action films you know like The
Terminator or Terminator 2 or Total
Recall or predator and then he has
movies like commando mindless
entertainment to the tenth degree
completely preposterous physics just out
the door gravity out the door everything
about commando is awesome though
The Last Stand is more like commando it
is a 100% mindless action film guys have
guns and they blow crap up if you go
into the last stand expecting the Oscar
caliber turn form Arnold Schwarzenegger
you are going to be extremely upset this
is a big dumb corny cheesy action movie
and it knows that 100% and that's why I
enjoyed the last stand there's no ifs
ands or buts about the last stand it is
exactly what it is and it knows that and
it does it well the film has a nice
impressive visual style it's nothing
remarkable there are some really
incredible shots in this movie though
this is one great shot where these guys
are going down these wires from one
building to the next and then the camera
pans down even farther into the street
and follows these cops running I was
really impressed with that shot and this
is a pretty cool action moments in this
movie including a really cool car chase
through the stalks of corn
that came up with some cool suspenseful
ways to tell that scene now how was
Arnold in this movie okay now this is a
return of Arnold Schwarzenegger he came
back in Expendables two but this is his
first fully starring role as a lead how
is he in this movie let me just tell you
a little secret it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger there you know you can't
critique and Arnold performance because
he has his own stamp on acting you can't
ever just go man he read that line wrong
man his accent really came through in
that one because it's freaking awesome
it's Arnold Schwarzenegger and there is
some really great just feeling seeing
that guy back kick and blood in the
movie here you can tell that he is
really invested in this movie and he did
a good job it's his character like
filled with depth and substance and
health not at all you don't know much
about him at all it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger and he's a sheriff and
he's gonna kick some butt and that's
basically the entire depth behind this
movie but I will say this though
something I loved about this movie and I
can't believe I never actually thought
of this ever in my life but I love this
as Arnold says in this movie when he
crashes through a door he's old he's
getting up there and this movie does not
portray him as an invincible guy who
just he does everything perfectly he
gets beat to crap in this movie and it
takes him a long time to get up and he's
limping up steps like holding the wall
and everything and at first I was like
wow this is actually I'm not used to
this because it was so cool to see him
as more of a vulnerable action hero
because I'm so used to seeing him as
these very invincible type guys seeing
him limping around and struggling to get
up it kind of added a really nice touch
to him as an action star and I never
really thought about that it's cool to
see him as this older guy and he's not
portrayed as some Superman guy he has a
hard time getting up sometimes in this
movie and added a different sense of a
lair to him as an action hero the movie
is cheesy and hammy some of the dialogue
by some of the actors which English is
not exactly their native tongue some of
its not delivered that well there are
corny moments there are police chief's
who obviously don't have an idea of what
it means to be a policeman there are FBI
agents who don't have any idea of what
FBI regulations are they say stuff
that's obviously just movie dialogue I
would say that was like a really whore
negative thing about this movie if the
movie was taking itself seriously but
since it's not it is what it is now one
of the things I was really worried about
in this movie when I saw the trailer
initially was the inclusion of Johnny
Knoxville
the trailer just had him in there's so
much I really thought he was just gonna
be this humongous presence and start to
be really annoying and everything I
don't dislike him as an actor I just I
didn't didn't seem like he fit in with
this movie he was actually one of the
more fun parts of the film for sure I
enjoyed his character he's basically
this guy who has like a gun museum in
the middle of nowhere and he was a fun
character but he wasn't overbearing he
actually added a fun presence to the
movie some could be really annoyed by
him I could see that happening but I
wasn't one of those people
overall The Last Stand is a big cheesy
violent dumb entertaining movie and it
knows exactly that and it's not trying
to be anything else
I'm going to give it a B welcome back
Arnold it is nice to have you back on
the big screen as always guys thanks for
watching and if you like this video you
can click right here and get stuck
menage
[Music]